sometimes the word feminism gets used
like you know crazy depending on your
interpretation of it i think we're
living in a generation now where women
are stepping up and women are
are becoming some of them
providers for themselves and whatnot and
but what i think is important is for
women to know
when to sit in your masculinity or once
it's in your femininity
so you're conditionally it is you're
conditional what do you mean i'm
conditional so one minute you're
masculine one minute you're feminine
no we're both everybody's both
everybody's both masculine and feminine
you both have the you everybody has to
show an estrogen yeah everybody has it
it's in it's in our dna
literally
so what i'm saying is sometimes when
women in the work fields go and present
themselves they sit in their masculinity
and some of the dumb some of them don't
know how to come home and sit in that
femininity you know what i mean flip the
switch that's the problem we're complex
creatures you're right and i'm saying
i'm saying for whoever's watching this
like as women who are successful need to
learn how to sit in their femininity
when need be
but i do think also some men who are
masculine do need to learn to sit in
their femininity
and be empathetic all the time is what
i'm trying to say
uh no do not be vulnerable with women i
i but you've never been you've never
been in love you won't do the example
women are not built to handle masculine
problems we are the being vulnerable
with a woman is some of the worst advice
that modern day women give to men
because if i sit there and i cried you
oh my god my life is hard
you might sit there and console me for a
bit but deep diving blood you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and you're gonna go and find
something so not sure i know
all right so you're saying that what
he's saying is incorrect
crying
human powerful
again this is a common example of women
saying one thing but doing another
they're saying this right now because
it's politically correct to say you can
cry to me you can be vulnerable to me et
cetera but deep down if your man came to
you and was crying on your shoulder
saying i don't know what's going on her
vagina's gonna him can i finish can i
finish her vagina's going to dry up she
ain't going to want to [ __ ] with him
anymore she's going to look for a
stronger more capable man because women
are designed to look for security just
because they cry once bro hey man i
can't tell you how many times we've
brought girls on the show with their own
they tell us on air
i one time my boyfriend cried in front
of me and i never looked at him the same
it's like a it's like a glass if you
shatter a glass right and it smashes
onto pieces and you glue it back
together yeah maybe it'll work but when
you pour water into it it's always going
to leak i can't move
you guys cry
like that's like the best sex i ever
have when a guy is vulnerable have you
done a poll let's do i mean let's do a
poll here we're going to is it
attractive
for a man to cry are you saying that all
the time for sure but when you see your
[ __ ] every
here's a big problem once again right
you're saying it's okay right for you
and for you it might be okay in this
moment however the next girl might say
you know what damn him even just crying
in this moment i lost interest so we
don't know how far so far and that's the
problem because you may say it's okay
but shimano says okay you're right and
as a guy why am i gonna make that chance
we're gonna say you know what i'm gonna
be the rock i'm gonna be her foundation
and i'm gonna be strong for her versus
and oh i'm gonna cry on her face and she
might leave yeah because you don't know
how the girl's gonna react because it's
a very it you have to love you have to
be in the relationship with a guy have
them cry from you show that inability to
provide security and then how you react
you might not necessarily know how
you're gonna react so what we tell guys
is don't be vulnerable with your girl
it's a waste of time and quite frankly
can i say can i please finish so the
thing is is that women do not handle
masculine problems men and women live
different realities women are not
equipped to handle masculine problems
you need to go to your guys and tell
them you have issues you want to cry cry
to them you have problems you want to
talk out talk it out with them because
you cannot show that you're soft or weak
in front of your woman because even
though women say oh well no i'm capable
of being empathetic i can understand
your struggle blah blah they really
don't because when a man cries in front
of a woman it's going to incite a
natural reaction of repulse of
revulsion because men that cry and are
soft are not attractive and women are
hardwired to look for security this is
why guys that are soft and lose frame
the girl leaves them and goes to another
guy that knows what's going on and it's
a very
um how do i say this
it's a it's a biological response you
know what i'm saying like women are just
designed to look for men that are strong
so we tell guys don't even get open up
pandora's box and get sensitive around
your girl so don't even don't show
emotion ever
sorry i can't is it my turn are you done
crying and telling her about your
problems is not a good move to go
obviously you know being human being a
human right you got to have some kind of
you know social calibration here being a
human is one thing but to sit there and
cry and tell her about your problems etc
where it's going to affect her mindset
as far as like damn can this is this guy
the one is he the one that's going to be
able to provide me security you don't
want to do that you want to go to your
guys let me ask brother let me ask you
sure
men are more logical women are more
emotional is that a fair statement yes
yeah is anybody disagreeing with that
statement no okay
can the logical male be a little
emotional is that fair well you just
said that women are not equipped to
handle masculine problems right that's
what you said are you no they're not in
a position to help their guy from are
men struggle equipped to handle
emotional problems without a woman
like the reverse i'm talking about the
reverse yeah because the difference is
if you cry on my shoulder i'm not gonna
lose attraction for you i'm talking
about your the issues in your life in
general do you not crave support from a
woman to be there for you like
when a man shows vulnerability it shows
that he trusts me to to share in that
moment and that's the kind of father i
want to raise my kid somebody who's
gonna be emotional when my kid breaks
down or something bad happens to not
just be like toughen up kid but to to
show empathy to make good humans that's
why i think your show is a little
dangerous because you're not telling men
to be empathetic or emotional ever in
this world yes it it it advances with
gains financial gains all that stuff but
we also have to create a beautiful
environment for us to enjoy each other
in and i think those your podcast is
super successful because people spend
twenty dollars to send hateful comments
you're inciting a lot of hate but
where's the like
the good energy guys before you respond
are you familiar with the concept the
philosophy of stoicism
yes okay would you consider
yourself a stoic yeah with yeah man
you're familiar with this really is
you've got to be stoic it's like because
here's the thing you're trying to say oh
i think that's destructive or whatever
what we're saying is we know that most
women and here's the thing ladies i need
you to kind of get out your own shoes
and understand that we're talking about
in generalities here not just you two if
i lined up 100 women right and i told a
guy all right man each of these are your
girlfriend go ahead and cry and be
vulnerable with them etc i would argue
that somewhere between 85 to 90 of them
are not going to like it so if there's
five or 10 that might like it it's a low
probability
that you're gonna be able to
successfully be vulnerable without
losing your girlfriend just to be clear
you've asked how many women this
question thousands we've asked yeah and
a lot of literally and they're able to
be honest and say hey and that's what
your findings are 80 plus percent we're
finding that most women hate soft men
whether the guy and a couple girls have
actually went a step further and
admitted yeah when he cried in front of
me i never looked at him the same and it
kind of killed it and we've had several
women say that so
they can say that now because it's
politically correct and we got the
cameras on et cetera but behind closed
doors if your boyfriend is crying in
front of you being solved i don't know
i'm gonna make the bills blah blah it's
not going to be attractive masculine
problems need to be solved by other men
you need that's why men need a tribe you
go and tell your guys your problems and
you come back home like nothing's going
on you're the stoic rock because women
are emotional you cannot be the
emotional one in the relationship
because here's the difference if a woman
cries on your shoulder and tells you oh
i'm having a rough day or whatever
you're in a position where you're not
going to lose attraction for your woman
for her being a woman and being
emotional however if you're in a man and
you're being emotional to your woman she
is going to lose attraction for you
despite the fact that she says i'm here
for you baby or whatever she's still
going to lose attraction and eventually
arousal and then leave for another guy
here's a good example right let's say
i'm at work right i have a problem at
work i may be possibly like in a
position where i may lose my job right
i go into my wife and say you know what
wife um i'm gonna lose my job i don't
know what to do i'm in trouble right
that's being more open i'm being more
emotional so to speak she might feel a
separate way about that versus if i say
for example hey i had a problem at work
i resolved it pack your bags going on
vacation what's the better what's the
better outlook for you
are those those two examples i mean
you're presenting one that with a a
reward and the other with the problem
hey good news we're going on vacation or
i just got fired yeah i see what you're
saying but see look i fixed the problem
and then i gave her like i just got a
reward versus here's the problem i
didn't fix it what's more sexy
we're talking about sexy
or yes so what's more attractive
real and we're human life is [ __ ]
hard sometimes you're gonna have down
moments and i'm i am an empathetic
person i can understand when a man goes
through a struggle i'm not gonna be
unattracted to you because you're living
life you're doing your best you're about
to be on the street
he can't work anymore
then we're going to figure it out
because we're partners and that's what
we signed up for
that sounds great on paper but it's not
how the reality is
you